soapios like these movies are kind of
defined by ambition but what is
something you managed to achieve on the
way of water that would make 2009 Avatar
making you go like I cannot believe we'd
actually be able to pull that off one
day no I I think what
um where we really got to on this movie
is about the close-up
I think that when you see Jake and the
teary and you see Loach and his feeling
you we could not rise to that level of
performance on the first film we
couldn't do it from a nuanced standpoint
we couldn't do it from a photo reality
standpoint in this movie we have those
CG characters standing right next to
human characters and you don't even
think twice about it my favorite thing
in this is the way that like rainfall
glistens off of them there's just like a
level of precision to that that I never
thought I'd ever say you know what we
really wanted to do is take our real
life experiences and we've been in the
rain and we've been in the water and
we've come up and Jim and I have both
Dove and know what the hair is like
afterwards and how the beads of of water
drip down you in salt water is different
than fresh water and all these different
things we really challenged what effects
to look at all that to learn that to
understand it and then we had we were
able to have an eye based on our life
experience to challenge them on a daily
basis to make it real they met that
challenge big time going back a little I
was reading about that technology Summit
you all did I think in February of 20 uh
2010 the idea of isolating what you
think worked really well in the first
film but then also picking things that
you thought that the team could improve
upon so can you give me an example of
each there you know yeah so we did you
know what is now referred to as a
retreat I used to call it a postmortem
Jim said to me John nobody died you
can't call it a postmortem okay Jim
um so we got together all of our
department heads and and we talked about
you know these type of things
a thing that worked well the first time
was what we call simulcam where we were
able to look through the lens of a
camera and see a CG character that
wasn't there but compositionally the
director could frame for it so like when
Jake Sully woke up the first time Jim
was able to compose seeing the CG
character there
what didn't work back then was that CG
character could only stand in front of
things like the weatherman stands in
front of a screen
so we challenged ourselves to do what we
call real-time depth compositing where
we would now have scenes where a
character could walk behind a CG
character or walk in front of them a CG
character could walk behind a desk so we
challenge the teams to come up with it
and no one had ever done that before and
they cracked that with all the
Innovative tools you've made up for this
series is there any particular one that
you're most looking forward to seeing
another production go on and use in the
future something not Avatar related look
I I think it's something that relates to
what we just talked about something that
relates to the depth compositing
something that relates to the simulcam
because not every movie has computer
generated characters in it but a lot of
movies now today shoot green screen or
blue screen and those elements aren't
there and and directors are left to try
and imagine what's there our tools allow
others to see what would be there and we
don't want ownership over these we want
these tools to become ubiquitous so that
more and more filmmakers do you use them
you change the game for the industry I
really could never have imagined you
upping the level of the technology in
this movie as much as you did and the
thought of this affecting movie making
and that craftsmanship in general is
just mind-blowing I think what you just
touched on I hope that it unlocks a door
that other filmmakers now really believe
if they dream it they can do it because
I want to see those movies I want to
experience those movies don't be limited
by what you think can be done if you
dream it it can be done does genuinely
feel like that when you watch this film
looking ahead a little I know James has
said that at some point in the future he
would be open to passing the directing
Reigns over to another filmmaker I have
a hard time I know there's wonderful
filmmakers out there I have a hard time
imagining anybody else on this planet
directing an Avatar movie than him do
you think that's a real possibility or
will it likely not happen look I I think
those are two different questions right
I do think it's a possibility because I
think you would have said the same thing
when Jim wrote his draft of elite a
battle angel
that that that that Jim's never going to
give this up for someone else to do and
we found a director who wanted to
continue with what our vision was of the
movie and allowed us to create a
partnership with Robert where I was on
the set every day with him we edited the
movie in Los Angeles you know we were
very much a part of the visual effects
so I think there are directors who can
do that and that was a great experience
I think Jim is saying it now because of
that experience with Robert I think that
proved to him that when he's ready there
will be someone do I ever think he's
going to be ready not sure about that
one I think I'm believing that I also
feel like you have a whole lot of
Technology here that would serve an
Elita sequel well because I know the
talk for that is never going away ever
people will always want another one of
those you know no one more so than we do
we want to do but you know we're also
the type of people we give 110 of
ourselves to whatever we do it's not
something we could have focused on in
the midst of Avatar weather of water
it's something that a couple weeks ago I
was talking to Robert we've had numerous
conversations so you know it's something
that we still want to happen the more
that character the more rows of salads
are this industry has the better right
Rosa oh my God she is amazing and again
what what her character and the way Rosa
played it
I I just love it and and it's you know
the story that is so relatable her
character and you know I say I say about
her she's not a perfect person she has
her flaws but she Rises up to to do it
and and um now she pulled it off it was
great I love it she's one of my
favorites speaking of the future of this
franchise and the technology because
like I said before i s I could never
have predicted how you raise the bar in
terms of the visuals in way of water but
given the fact that we're gonna get
three and hopefully four and five a lot
sooner than we did this second movie
what can people go into those next
sequels expecting in terms of you
continuing to raise the bar with the
tech well I think we're going to
continue to raise the bar with the
storytelling first I think that you know
as as what we're going to do is go out
and meet new clans we're going to go out
and see different biomes and that's
going to present its own technological
challenges how do we present those just
like water presented challenges in this
one and what we're going to also
continue to do is not look at just how
we use the tools of Technology but how
do we get the exhibition community on
board with creating a ubiquitous
improved meant across all theaters
because that's what we have to do is we
compete with more and more home home
streaming and bigger screens it's not
just what the content we create it's a
partnership with exhibition I harped on
the tech a lot here but one of my
favorite things about the movie you'll
see in my tweet later is that all these
incredible visuals always feel like
they're in service of character and
storytelling first and foremost Beyond
just having a pretty picture for us to
look at and I appreciate it well no
thank you I mean that is our whole focus
is on that and if somebody says what are
you trying to do in any moment it's to
create an actor descent actor
director-centric process that allows an
audience to experience Kate Winslet
Stephen Lang Sigourney Weaver Britain
Dalton took bread and so great I mean
look I I said to Margie simpkin or
casting director did a phenomenal job uh
even Jamie flatters you know and how he
underplays his big moment and you know
those type of things I love it